[Music]
hello Bruce
it's time for an update vlog I've been
holding out on you I've been waiting to
do this because I thought a little a
year review was in good time
for the holidays to do it's been quite
the year I don't know if you've noticed
it's probably been the most insane year
of my life literally so many things to
scott completely switched up aside down
lost a lot of friends lost a lot of a
lot of things but i'm looking back on 20
or 17 and it doesn't feel negative it
doesn't feel like i'm necessarily a bad
thing and i will try and explain why at
around this time last year I made a
video saying that I was gonna delete my
channel at 50 million bread 58 million
now by the way thank you very much I
know you're gonna think I'm joking right
now but I'm gonna delete my channel
I swear to you at 50 million subs when
we hit 50 million a huge landmark coming
up a huge deal never never been done
before no one's even close I am deleting
my channel so dramatic I'm gonna delete
my channel I had 60 million guys I
promise it's definitely going to happen
that was sort of a joke but at the same
time I didn't feel like that was
necessarily the case I really felt like
I wanted to delete my channel because I
was so stuck in between all these
business side of you toons you didn't
see a fraction of it but for me to do
YouTube every single day upload daily
videos and still be going on trips world
these different events going on trip for
business stuff having calls every single
day talking about you know rebel mode
and all these things I was working on
and working on scare PewDiePie being
away for a month
I was so burned out and I know boohoo me
right I put myself in that situation but
I realized this is not why I'm stuck
here and I this is not what I want I
just want to make videos well I what the
hell happened I literally went through
like an actual mental breakdown it just
got too much for me and I think I have a
really strong mental psyche like I can
handle more [ __ ] than most people I feel
confident saying that but it really got
to me at a point and I'm not trying to
get brown like at points that's not the
case so when all this stuff happened in
February when all this stuff about me
being a Nazi came out some things of it
was awful the fact that scare PewDiePie
season 2 got canceled
just sucked I don't in any retrospect it
does it still doesn't make any sense to
me so many people worked on that show it
it's it's really it's a shame for
everyone that involved and I'm really
sorry for everyone involved but it also
got me out of all these things that I
didn't even enjoy working on at the time
I was so fed up with it so it was sort
of a blessing in disguise and and this
year in general the main thing
throughout all these bad things
happening I regained so much support
from you guys and it's something that I
never thought I would get back I've sort
of given up on the idea that my friends
were really gonna have this consensus of
community again and you know for all
these bad things to trade that I would
take it it's just been amazing
then the apocalypse happened oh boy and
I vowed to go family-friendly that
worked that great didn't it to be honest
when the apocalypse happened I I did get
hit really hard it was a time of panic
because all the sudden none of your
videos are you're not getting any income
with there all the Wall Street stuff
happening my CPM which is like my
average income thing dropped because I
was kicked out of YouTube
what is it called there's special ad
program or whatever but then I realized
hey I can literally just put one extra
mineral in the video and it doesn't make
any difference I like I actually don't
lose anything and so I started doing
that as a way to like you know what fu
wallstreet you're not gonna make me go
down you know it's not that I need the
money it was more like I want to show
them that this is not gonna affect me in
any way so in case you're wondering why
there's a mid role there you go at the
end of the day I used to have an office
I used to have a bunch of people working
for me but I also realized I didn't want
that I used to have like a secretary
helping me get coffee and like I don't
really feel comfortable letting other
people do stuff for me it really wasn't
what I wanted at all so I just panicked
I got super sick like the worst sickness
of my life and I decided to hey I can
just record from this place it's so much
more convenient I don't have to have
other people in the other room when I
record this is how I started making
videos in this room and that's how I
want to keep I want to keep it simple I
would always say like Oh YouTube isn't
the best because you get just me and
it's not me and a producer and a writer
but I had all these people helping me do
all this stuff and it really felt like I
was getting against what I was so spoken
about before so I got really sick and
then this Jake Paulus tough kid came out
and it was like the best that was like
the best thing that could that could
happen because I find I had something to
just make a video rub right away when I
was away which is always nice and this
is when I decided I'm gonna grow a beard
keemstar trying to roast my beard I made
a video called I'm tired of trying where
I basically talked that I really used to
be very focused on trends I used to be
very focused on like how well a video
did that would take up a lot of my mind
space and hey I think most youtubers
think like that I realize I don't want
to
I don't want to shape my channel that
way I want to do what I want to do I
want to make the kind of videos that I
enjoy making and that has been my
mindset for the past couple months and
it's just turn out so much better you
know whether it's me talking about
something that I enjoy like whiskey that
for me has just been really fun I've
been enjoying just sharing stuff that I
like and I think you guys have as well
and it's been really fun too
and it's such a better way of making
videos maybe he doesn't get as many
views but it's more fun and I would
rather watch someone talk about stuff
that they like then [ __ ] play a game
that they don't really enjoy I started
doing these love love Y videos where I
react to your reddit stuff and that was
just the best idea ever
I know it's like a mean that it's not
original content and nice or whatever
but it really came back the the sort of
community on the channel seeing your
humor and my humor sort of collide into
different type of memes it's so cool and
so fun and I loved it so much I love
that we find it we have a community on
this channel rather than just me just
doing random [ __ ] playing random
games I'm really proud of that I'm
really proud that we are at this point
where we are and that really thanks for
everyone for posing in these started
doing your laugh you losses which was
also kind of thing we're like people
didn't like in the beginning they were
like we're just looking at other
people's click but are you ray william
johnson I enjoyed it I just like I
enjoyed making them they were fun I love
laughing at these stupid clips so why
shouldn't I make them and I'm really
glad I kept doing them because I think
you guys actually really liked
[Music]
man and I started streaming cuz I was
really into pub G and I don't think I
before I was so preoccupied with YouTube
I had literally no other interest
it was YouTube or nothing I was all that
was in my head 24/7 a day so I allowed
myself to enjoy other things and
actually playing games again on my spare
time and that's why I enjoyed streaming
so much this is the day before the
slipper I hate how it's a [ __ ] unfair
dude shoot me shoot me
where's his nipa oh my god then the
slip-up happened and definitely you know
once a year not even worth once every 10
years not even but like twice a year you
didn't idiot and this time it was sort
of different because I felt personally
responsible I felt like you know this is
my fault I shouldn't even I shouldn't
even defend this and that's what I did
I'm really glad for all the support I
still got even though I clearly [ __ ]
up but I'm glad people accepted my
apology and I was able to move past it
I really started making videos that just
about stuff that fascinated me like
Christian
or just talking about memes or okay it's
not original content yes I know but I
love talking about these things I love
sharing these things and I think it's so
much more interesting to hear someone
talk about something they're interested
in and that's has been my approach would
I ever make a [ __ ] Star Wars review
in 2016 hell no but did I really have a
lot of thoughts about the movie that I
wanted to share yes and that's why I did
it and I think it's such a better
approach and I'm so happy I stuck with
it there's so much has changed this year
but at the end of the year I am so much
happier I'm so glad I'm here finally
Internet it's gonna be installed on the
22nd maybe that has happened already
even me just keeping my skin weird
because this is kind of thing where
everyone in the comments will tell you
just shave just shave and I'm like well
I like the beard I'm gonna keep it it's
really I know it sounds stupid but I I
really think I I'm really proud of
myself for gaining a lot more confidence
in myself to resist what other people
say I should do or how other people tell
me how to how to do things it's so easy
to listen to comments I think I really
think everyone does but I think at the
end of the day people appreciate that
you are you and not just a product of
what other people want you to be that
sounded a lot deeper than I meant it to
be I'm also just really grateful that I
can keep making videos at this point you
look at anyone else that's been number
one on YouTube and it's practically a
dead Channel and they didn't last very
long so for me at this point to still be
relevant enough that people care what I
say and what I do and and click on my
videos that really means the world to me
because I still very much enjoy videos I
get so many haters saying like oh if I
was pretty pie I would just quit making
videos he already made millions what an
idiot
maybe I'm passionate about it maybe I
still enjoy it it's like I really think
2017 was year where I lost
a lot of support from YouTube but it's
the year where I regained the support
from my fans and that I will never
forget because I went through somebody
changes so it felt like so many of my
fans hated me or whatever I'm just so
glad that finally we have a community
and finally again and finally we have I
have people that I really feel like
there's people that support me I really
do I feel that finally and that that
really means a lot so thank you it's
been despite all the downsides it's been
an amazing year and I'm really proud and
happy looking back believe it or not you
learn from your mistakes and that's just
life that's life that's a room reference
everybody thank you to everyone for
hanging out with me this year can't wait
for next one and as always squad fam
should we do should we do a breakfast
I'll let it slide this time
[Music]